we are live here on sky news at
buckingham palace following proceedings
all day and we are joined by a very
special guest it's almost like having
royalty here it is dave joanna lovely
how lovely to be i can't tell you how
thrilling it is to be here because to
watch it on television is something but
to be here and actually see the physical
thing the sound of the horses the bands
the glittering and the crowds just
thrown it's really enchanting yeah it
has been such a special couple of hours
rihanna let's talk about what we've
witnessed where should we start i think
the main focal point was the carriage
procession with the royals and we saw
the queen's youngest great-grandchildren
we saw princess george and louie and
princess charlotte their first carriage
procession that's right of course this
is a weekend like no other we have never
seen a platinum jubilee in this country
before no other monarch has ever marked
70 years on the throne and yes there's
the big official pageantry and spectacle
but also i think we're reminded that at
the center of this there is a family who
all want to come together to celebrate
this amazing milestone for their mother
their grandmother and their great
grandmother and so i think that is why
uh prince william and kate decided that
today was the right moment when prince
george
pritz louis and princess charlotte
should all have their moment in a
carriage and we saw them riding past and
have to say prince george slightly
tentative about his waving but louie and
charlotte definitely giving it a good go
and um and yeah william and kate
and we can show you the pictures now
and they were in a carriage with the
duchess of cornwall as well
and yeah there you go princess charlotte
she's a little star in the making i
think
her wave is spot on joanna what struck
you about what we've watched unfold over
the last hour or so
it's the usual thing i mean it's just
extraordinary to see british ceremony at
its very very best and being the
daughter of a soldier i'm always
terribly proud to see the military out
absolutely can you think how hard it is
to ride a horse and play a musical
instrument and stay in line and follow
orders
so all of them together it's you know
it's like one of those it's just
sensational and there's such a huge buzz
of affection from everybody here when
every time the the um the
you know god save the queen is played
everybody stands up everybody's craning
their necks hoping to see them and then
to see them literally marching past here
that's wonderful and here's this lovely
look at that
and even though all the costumes are
kind of sent set from another century we
almost don't want them ever to change we
don't want to see them in t-shirts and
jeans we want to see them
full ceremonial
and riding on today which is hot and the
horses have all got sheepskin blankets
under their saddles and there's
all the can you imagine the uniforms and
they've got bare skin hats and swords oh
astonishing it is a real feat of
endurance and a real source of pride uh
for those in the armed forces taking
part today john i'd just like to ask
because this is the first time we're
seeing you on screen you're gonna be
with us on sunday as well for the big
parade what does this platinum jubilee
mean to you
well it's extraordinary because 69 years
ago today the queen was crowned and i
was a little girl out in malaysia my
father was with his gurkha regiment out
there
and we watched the coronation on black
and white films twice and then once in
color but of course we didn't know this
country we didn't know what london
looked like and on the day of the
coronation it was drizzling and wet and
we looked at these strange grey streets
and this extraordinary ceremony going on
and this tiny figure walking up the
aisle at westminster abbey and my heart
just went out even though i was only
seven at the time i just thought this is
one of the most marvelous people in the
world a fairy story yeah
and it's lovely to see no no i
understand because i now know london to
know that all these soldiers are going
back to wellington barracks which is
only just around the side we forget that
huge army headquarters are here bang in
the middle of london